german car maker volkswagen is facing
prosecutors in the country over
allegations of human rights violations
at a farm it ran
during brazil's military dictatorship
accusations include include slave labor
torture and even killings prosecutors
say they have documented years of
atrocities committed by volkswagen
managers in the 1970s and 80s and now
they hope to reach a financial
settlement for the victims
a courthouse in brasilia here behind
closed doors prosecutors were set to
confront one of the world's most
powerful automakers with a series of
explosive allegations it revolves around
this farm in brazil the accusation that
volkswagen benefited from slave labor
here during the 1970s and 80s
my father it was a form of modern
slavery
workers had to work seven days a week
more than 10 hours a day without any pay
the prosecution alleges that there are
hundreds of cases in which serious human
rights violations occurred
they say workers were little more than
indentured servants
witnesses speak of being shackled after
attempting to escape being forced to
work at gunpoint and even of murder
when someone tried to escape the
managers would go after them and shoot
them
they beat up those who tried to escape
on the street in the shacks
volkswagen bought the farm in 1973 at
the invitation of brazil's military
dictatorship
today the company says they take the
accusations seriously but must first
analyze the results of the investigation
before commenting
this surprises christopher copper who
says he informed volkswagen of its
involvement a few years ago
i examined the operations of this farm
during my studies in 2017.
after my discovery i told volkswagen
that during this period it had used
foreign laborers
who were essentially forced into slavery
brazil's prosecutor now wants justice
we are convinced that volkswagen will
acknowledge its responsibility and that
there will be a settlement with the
prosecutor's office and the former
workers brazilian society will be
compensated for these unacceptable
incidents
it's unclear how volkswagen will respond
to the allegations
we asked our correspondent matthias eva
to what extent volkswagen management
knew about what was going on
they knew about it and there were
reports already in the 80s in the german
magazine spiegel about it so there were
rumors about it um
for decades already and but lately in
2017 uh the historian christopher copper
which we heard in the report he
published his report um
and folks like knew about
these
accusations and about the the what
happened at this farm because mr copper
dedicated one chapter uh on this farm in
the para state in brazil so they knew
about it also the management but um yeah
we don't know why they didn't act so far
that's one of the secrets volkswagen
might
might tell us about
in the next months which are to come
you